R René Lévesque aurait eu 1000s
cecet été, il est né le 22 août
191922. C'est à l'occasion
dedes événements entourant
cece 100 ème aniversaire que
j'j'ai rencontré Lucien Bouchar:
didiscussion autour de l'héritae
dede René  Lévesque, bien sûr,
dede la souveraineté du PQ
dudu pragmatisme de Francois
lelegault mais du danger aussi e
rereprésente des oppositions trp
fafaibles. Ça prend
unune alternative selon lui
etet vous allez voir l'ancien
prpremier ministre s'inquiete
dadavantage du sort du parti
lilibéral que de celui
dede son ancien parti.
M.M. Bouchard, bonjour.
- - Bonjour.
- - On a rendu un dernier hommae
àà Guy Lafleur il y a peu de
tetemps. Et beaucoup de gens ont
sosouligné sa sincérité, et ont
sosouligné à quel point il est
dedevenu important, parce qu'il
ététait respecté, bien sûr,
mamais il était aimé. Ce genre e
héhéros-là dans notre histoire,
ilil n'y en a pas tant que ça.
ReRené Lévesque fait partie
dede ces gens-là. Pourquoi,
popour vous, c'était important
dede participer à cette année
ouoù on va souligner l'importane
dede M. Lévesque?
- - C'est important parce que
ReRené Lévesque est important.
- - Cette entreprise ne nous
pepermet pas seulement de prévor
l'l'avenir, elle constitue dès
mamaintenant une des clés majeus
dudu développement aussi autonoe
quque possible du Québec.
(a(applaudissements)
- - René Lévesque est un des pls
grgrands personnages politiquesu
QuQuébec. C'est tout naturellemt
quque Lucien Bouchard a accepté
dede présider les célébrations
enentourant son 100e anniversai.
VoVous aimez les mots,
M.M. Bouchard. Je vais vous donr
ququelques mots et vous allez me
didire ce que ça évoque pour vos
ququand vous pensez à M. Lévesq.
FiFierté. Bon.
LULUCIEN BOUCHARD, ancien premir
miministre du Québec (1996-2001)
- - C'était le coeur de ce que
ReRené Lévesque voulait faire
etet ce qu'il faisait. Il voulat
ininsuffler de la fierté
auaux Québécois. Et il savait
ququ'on était un peuple qui a éé
mamagané par l'histoire,
évévidemment. Il l'a raconté
sosouvent, il l'a vécu lui auss.
IlIl voulait qu'on en sorte...
dede la bonne façon.
PaPas négativement, pas par
rereprésailles, pas par rancune,
mamais en faisant un pas en avat
popour nous élever nous-mêmes
papar une conscience plus claire
dede ce qu'on est capables de
fafaire. Je pense qu'il a réussi
enen très grande partie.
AÀ refaire un peu l'image
ququ'on a de nous-mêmes depuis.
OuOui, c'est vrai, mais quand
ilil avait ses phrases
exextraordinaires, René, "quelqe
chchose comme un grand peuple"..
IlIl avait le sens des mots aus.
IlIl avait vraiment le sens
dedes mots, la façon d'exprimer
leles choses au bon moment.
EtEt c'était pas calculé,
onon sentait pas qu'il avait des
cocomités, des gens de relations
pupubliques. Non, c'était
spspontané, c'était immédiat..
EtEt c'était plein de vérité.
- - Pragmatisme.
- - Oui, il connaissait le sens
dedes limites, en politique.
IlIl savait jusqu'où ça devient
imimpossible. Et que le danger,
c'c'est de franchir la ligne...
ququi fait tomber dans l'échec,
dadans le rejet, dans
lala suprématie de l'angoisse
etet des inquiétudes. Parce que
soson projet, c'est un projet qi
ététait exigent, qui demandait
énénormément aux Québécois.
DeDe franchir la ligne
dede l'inconnu. Et il savait
quque c'était normal que dans
unune psychologie collective,
onon se pose la question : est-e
ququ'on va oser aller jusque-là?
IlIl l'avait dit lui-même. C'est
papas le "bag"... Il y avait un
momot... c'est pas l'archipel, .
- - "C'est pas le goulag."
- - "C'est pas le goulag",
lele Canada, pour nous,
leles Québécois. Seulement de de
çaça, il n'y a pas beaucoup de
popoliticiens qui sont capables
dede faire une concession commea
avavant de partir.
- - Timoré, justement. Timoré.
- - Il était pas timoré. Il avat
dudu courage. Mais en même temp,
ilil était prudent puis il était
susurtout conscient qu'on peut s
enen demander trop aux gens.
ReRené Lévesque en a jamais vouu
auaux Québécois d'avoir voté non
auau référendum. Jusqu'à
unun certain point, il partageat
égégalement leurs inquiétudes.
- - À la présidence, le député
dede Montréal-Laurier et leader
dudu MSA, M. René Lévesque.
(a(applaudissements)
- - Mais avant l'inquiétude,
ilil y a eu en effet le courage.
LeLe courage de changer de rout.
191966, René Lévesque, qui aurat
pupu rester libéral, plaide pour
lala Souveraineté-Association.
IlIl quitte le PLQ, il quitte
dedes frères politiques, des am,
mmême, pour aller fonder
lele Parti québécois.
LuLucien Bouchard, à l'été 1990,
ququitte lui aussi son ami
BrBrian Mulroney pour fonder
lele Bloc québécois.
EtEt il comprend mieux que
lala plupart des gens le prix
àà payer pour écouter
seses convictions.
M.M. Bouchard, quelles qualités
çaça prend? On se remet dans
lele contexte, 1966 : M. Lévesqe
sosort de l'idée dominante,
ilil sort du sentier battu
etet crée quelque chose.
QuQuelles qualités ça prend
popour être capable de sortir
dede la pensée dominante?
- - Ça prend un sens incroyable
dede l'importance du sens critie
pupuis de la liberté personnell.
IlIl l'avait au maximum.
EtEt un courage! Rompre avec son
mimilieu, rompre avec ses comba.
ReRené Lévesque avait plein d'as
dadans la Parti libéral.
IlIls avaient fait des choses
foformidables ensemble durant
ceces années-là au pouvoir.
LeLe parcours, les réussites
dudu Parti libéral, tout court.
PaParce que le Parti libéral,
c'c'est un grand parti qui a
lalaissé un grand patrimoine
auaux Québécois, et j'espère
ququ'il va se remonter parce que
çaça nous prend une alternative,
àà l'avenir. Mais René Lévesque
avavait vécu ces années-là,
inintenses, où la Révolution
trtranquille, le Québec moderne.
AvAvec ses amis, ses compagnons,
leles Gérin-Lajoie.
- - L'électricité!
MeMettre de l'ordre dans
leles moeurs électorales,
lele sens de l'éthique... C'état
exextraordinaire, les réussites
dede ces années-là. Alors, rompe
avavec cette équipe, avec ses
amamis, ç'a dû prendre un courae
énénorme. Il a dû être très
mamalheureux, d'ailleurs. Il a û
lele vivre très malheureusement.
RoRompre avec des amis, rompre
avavec des gens qui nous sont
chchers, c'est dur.
C'C'est peut-être la pire chose
ququ'on soit appelé à faire
unun jour en politique si jamais
onon pense qu'on peut pas
cocontinuer. Donc, il était
lologique parce qu'il a vu
ququ'il pouvait pas continuer.
DoDonc, ça prend de la lucidité,
mamais après, ça prend tout
unun courage pour aller au bout
dudu diagnostic qu'on a posé.
- - Vous parlez de rupture.
EÉvidemment, la vôtre avec
M.M. Mulroney, c'est dans
cecet ordre-là. Est-ce que c'est
unune blessure que vous avez
enencore, ça?
- - Oui, sûrement. Sûrement.
IlIl faut dire que c'est pas
nénécessaire, en politique,
ququ'on en arrive là.
MaMais les enjeux étaient tels,
dadans ces périodes de la vie
popolitique au Québec et
auau Canada, qu'à un moment don,
onon était exposés à ça.
AÀ un moment donné, il y avait
dedes choix épouvantables à fai.
QuQui laissent des traces et ne
sese réparent à peu près jamais.
BoBon, M. Mulroney et moi,
onon entretient des rapports
cicivils. On se parle, on peut
sese parler au téléphone,
onon se rencontre, on discute
dedes choses qui nous rapproche,
onon parle surtout de nos enfan,
enen particulier. Parce que c'et
vrvrai, je connais ses enfants,
ilil connaît les miens et tout.
EtEt puis, mes enfants aiment
bebeaucoup M. Mulroney.
PuPuis moi, je m'entends bien ac
seses enfants aussi. Mais il y a
cecette blessure dont on ne pare
papas. On ne parle pas de
cecette blessure, on parle
dedes choses qui nous rapprochet
plplus que de celles qui nous ot
enennuyées à l'époque.
- - C'est pas sur votre liste,
M.M. Bouchard, d'essayer
unun souper, je sais pas où,
ququand, comment...
- - Peut-être. Peut-être.
IlIl y a des soupers, mais il ya
plplus de monde autour.
- - Non, mais une vraie rencont.
- - Je vais vous dire : le soupr
dede la réconciliation, ça,
çaça devient très, très diffici.
MaMais vous savez, on n'est pas
leles seuls à avoir vécu cela,
paparce que... Prenez M. Parizeu
etet M. Lévesque. Moi,
j'j'ai toujours senti que
M.M. Parizeau... je dirais pas
reregrettait, mais avait encore
cecette blessure d'avoir rompu
avavec René Lévesque.
- - Rupture, trahison.
LaLa politique est un opéra
paparfois merveilleux, parfois
d'd'une grande cruauté.
♪♪ ♪ ♪
191984, René Lévesque est brisé.
IlIl y a eu, coup sur coup,
lele rapatriement unilatéral où
ilil perd la partie devant Trudu
etet ensuite, un affrontement
dodouloureux avec les syndicats
dede la fonction publique.
ArArrive à Ottawa, fraîchement
élélu, Brian Mulroney avec son
ofoffre de réintégrer le Québec
dadans la constitution.
- - Ensemble, nous, du prochain
gogouvernement conservateur,
nonous allons, espérons-le,
etet de bonne foi, convaincre
l'l'Assemblée nationale du Québc
dede donner son assentiment
àà la nouvelle constitution
cacanadienne avec honneur
etet enthousiasme.
(a(applaudissements)
- - Le fameux discours
dede Sept-Îles, écrit par
LuLucien Bouchard. René Lévesque
acaccepte ce qu'il appellera
"l"le beau risque du fédéralisme
rerenouvelé". Résultat :
c'c'est la brisure.
LeLe départ de cinq ministres,
dodont Camille Laurin et Jacques
PaParizeau, qui n'acceptent pas
quque Lévesque tourne le dos
àà la souveraineté.
LeLe beau risque.
LULUCIEN BOUCHARD, ancien premir
miministre du Québec (1996-2001)
- - Le beau risque.
M.M. Parizeau est un homme
sesensible, aussi. Plus sensible
ququ'on pourrait le penser.
EtEt sa relation avec M. Lévesqe
ététait une relation compliquée,
unune relation complexe
d'd'admiration, de respect.
DeDeux grands personnages
enensemble, dans la même équipe,
ququi, à un moment donné, se sot
séséparés. Un moment critique.
M.M. Lévesque en a souffert
bebeaucoup, énormément.
EtEt M. Parizeau m'a déjà donné
àà entendre lui aussi qu'il
cocomprenait ce qu'on éprouve
dede... de peine d'avoir dû rome
avavec... Parce que vous savez,
dadans la vie, on ne reconstitue
papas les amitiés comme ça.
SuSurtout les amitiés
dede jeunesse, des amitiés qui
dedeviennent presque fraternell.
EtEt de les rompre, évidemment
quque ça laisse des traces.
EtEt ça peut pas se ressouder
vrvraiment. Parce que ç'a été d.
- - En 1980, René Lévesque accee
lala défaite.
- - Si je vous ai bien compris..
vovous êtes en train de dire :
àà la prochaine fois.
(a(applaudissements)
- - Mais certains au PQ auraient
vovoulu qu'il poursuive la quête
dudu grand jour, plutôt que
dede tenter le beau risque.
MMême chose pour Lucien Bouchard
apaprès les résultats serrés
dede 1995 : des péquistes
sosouhaitaient un match revanche
rarapide.
- - Merci!
(a(applaudissements)
- - Les purs et durs lui ont
rereproché, à M. Lévesque,
d'd'aller dans cette voie-là,
dede s'engager dans cette voie-.
VoVous, il y a des gens qui
auauraient voulu, au lendemain
dudu référendum de 1995, que
vovous refassiez un autre match
rerevanche. On vous a reproché .
PuPuis vous êtes allé plutôt
dadans le déficit zéro.
- - Oui, d'en perdre un troisièe
réréférendum, vous savez. De
peperdre un troisième référendu.
- - Vous êtes convaincu
auaujourd'hui?
- - Mais oui, bien sûr. Ça aurat
étété d'une irresponsabilité
fofondamentale de s'exposer
àà un troisième échec! On serait
papassé en dessous du plancher,
apaprès. Franchement, on peut ps
fafaire de référendum au Québec,
etet c'est pour ça que personne
y y pense aujourd'hui, sans avor
unun minimum de certitude
d'd'un homme raisonnable qu'on a
dede bonnes chances de gagner.
C'C'était pas le cas après
cece référendum-là. C'était pas
lele cas, je le sais. Le parti
ététait épuisé. Le Parti québécs
ététait épuisé. Les ressources,
ilil n'y en avait plus. Les gens
nene demandent pas de référendum
àà ce moment-là. Les gens
vovoulaient... ils se demandaiet
unun peu comment on va en sorti,
lala démission de M. Parizeau,
l'l'échec de 1995 et ainsi
dede suite. Il fallait rebâtir
unun minimum de confiance.
IlIl fallait rebâtir autour
dede l'État québécois, autour
dede l'intégrité des finances
pupubliques, qui étaient très
memenacées, à l'époque.
- - Donc, vous comprenez bien
l'l'état dans lequel il s'est
trtrouvé quand, après, il a dû
alaller chercher 700 millions ds
lala poche des travailleurs
ququébécois. Vous, vous dites :
ououi, il y a l'idéal de
lala souveraineté puis les purs
etet durs nous disent ceci.
MaMais il y a la réalité aussi
ququi nous rattrape.
- - M. Roy, les appuis
fofondamentaux du Parti québéco,
c'c'était le monde syndical.
CÇa commençait là. C'était des
apappuis presque inconditionnel.
EtEt le grave... le coup le plus
grgrave qui a été porté au monde
sysyndical, c'est cette décision
dede René Lévesque, de son
gogouvernement de diminuer
leles salaires de la fonction
pupublique jusqu'à 20 %.
PePendant une période de temps.
PuPuis ensuite de les remettre
àà niveau qui ne serait pas
cecelui du niveau du départ.
CÇa, c'est... puis par une loi,
papar la volonté, par l'autorité
dede l'État, l'autorité brutale
dede l'État. René Lévesque n'a s
fafait ça de gaieté de coeur.
EnEncore une fois, il s'est
cocomporté comme un homme réalie
etet responsable. Oui, ce serait
teterrible pour la suite
dedes choses, quant au rapport
enentre le Parti québécois
etet ses appuis traditionnels,
cece n'était pas un antisyndical
nonon plus, René Lévesque.
IlIl avait, comme on le sait,
unun préjugé prosyndical
trtrès accentué. Mais c'était
l'l'intégrité de l'État québéco.
OnOn était sur le point d'être
dédécotés. Et on ne pouvait pas
rerespecter les engagements
ququi avaient été pris dans
leles conventions collectives,
ququi comportaient une indexatin
tototale. Et l'inflation montait
àà 14 %. Alors là, il fallait
sasauver l'État! Sauver l'État.
C'C'est ce qui a de plus importt
chchez nous. Donc, il a osé.
IlIl s'est déchiré. Il s'est
dédéchiré le coeur, c'est sûr.
CÇa a été dur, la carrière
popolitique de René Lévesque.
C'C'est une suite de montagnes
rurusses et d'exaltations.
LaLa victoire de 1976 et ainsi
dede suite. De grandes réussites
dadans son gouvernement.
MaMais en même temps, des échecs
ququi laissent des traces
dadans la constitution,
dadans nos pouvoirs collectifs
etet ainsi de suite.
- - Est-ce que son véhicule
ququ'il a créé, vous êtes d'avis
ququ'il est, en effet, sur le bd
dede la mort...
- - On parle du Parti québécois?
- - On parle du parti, pas
dede l'idée de la souveraineté.
- - Je pense que M. Lévesque a
totoujours fait la distinction
enentre son objectif, qui était
lala souveraineté du Québec,
lala restauration de la plénitue
dede l'État du Québec,
etet le véhicule pour y arriver.
IlIl a voulu le faire au sein
dudu Parti libéral. Ça n'a pas
mamarché. Bon, les autres
vovoulaient pas aller jusque-là.
AlAlors, il s'est créé un véhice
àà lui. Mais c'était pas un home
dede parti, René Lévesque.
C'C'était pas un bon chef
dede parti. Moi j'étais un mauvs
chchef de parti, peut-être encoe
plplus que lui. Parce que quand
onon a un parti, il faut
s's'entendre avec le parti.
IlIl faut le flatter, il faut
fafaire un peu ce qu'il veut.
CÇa prend tout un tempérament...
- - Ça l'achalait, ça...
- - ... qui n'est pas
momon tempérament, mais c'était
papas le sien, encore moins.
ReRené Lévesque, ça l'achalait.
- - Est-ce qu'on va assister,
M.M. Bouchard, là, là, bientôt,
àà la mort de ce véhicule-là?
- - Bien, ce véhicule-là,
vovous savez, si le véhicule est
ususé puis que les gens n'en
veveulent plus, bien on en
chchoisira un autre. Ce qui est
imimportant, c'est le rêve
ququ'il animait. Ça, ça meurt p,
unun rêve. Le rêve est toujours
llà.
- - Il se porte comment,
cece rêve de la souveraineté?
- - Bien, pour le moment...
popour le moment, il est un peu
tatamisé. Il est encore là,
jeje pense, très fort, mais
dede penser le traduire dans
unune réalité à travers
leles activités d'un parti,
d'd'un référendum, on n'est pas
llà. On n'est pas là.
- - On n'est plus làà?
OnOn sera là un jour?
- - Qui connaît l'avenir?
QuQu'est-ce qui peut arriver?
L'L'avenir s'érige de n'importe
ququoi, s'érige de tous
leles possibles, l'avenir.
AlAlors oui, il y a un projet
sosouverainiste qui a animé
totoute une génération, qui noua
fafait faire des choses très
cocorrectes, dans l'intégrité,
dadans l'honneur, dans le respet
dedes individus, de la démocrate
aussssi. N'est-ce pas? Quand 95%
dedes gens votent à un référendm
cocomme en 1995 puis qu'il n'y a
papas un incident de violence,
çaça prend tout un peuple
dédémocratique pour réussir
unune chose comme celle-là. Oui.
MaMais l'idée, le projet,
c'c'est un rêve. C'est égalemen,
jeje pense, une nécessité
popolitique, quand on regarde
l'l'histoire du Québec.
OnOn ne peut pas se laisser
dédépouiller comme ça se passe
prprésentement. On est acculés
dadans le coin. La langue
frfrançaise, menacée. Non.
IlIl faut garder l'idée,
ilil faut garder la déterminati.
MaMais comment? Ça, on le sait
papas. Quelle forme ça va prend,
cece projet-là? Ça va se
trtransformer comment?
CÇa ne sera peut-être pas
unun projet souverainiste,
séséparatiste, comme on dit...
MaMais c'est certain qu'il y a
ququelque chose qui ne mourra ps
etet qui va s'exprimer d'une fan
ouou d'une autre dans la vie
popolitique québécoise.
DoDonc, moi, je ne suis pas
dédésespéré à l'idée que
lele Parti québécois va pas bie.
CÇa me désespère pas.
- - Même s'il ne serait plus là,
popour vous...
LULUCIEN BOUCHARD, ancien premir
miministre du Québec (1996-2001)
- - Entre nous, il ne mérite pas
dede très bien aller non plus.
C'C'est pas fort, là. Vous save,
c'c'est pas... C'est du bon mon.
PuPuis il y en a, des gens, pour
ququi j'ai beaucoup de respect.
PuPuis ils ont du mérite.
MaMais disons que... il y a
ququelque chose qui ne clique ps
dadans le débat politique.
- - Il y a quelque chose comme
unun supplice aussi. On a mal pr
ceces militants qui restent là.
- - Peux-tu imaginer... Peut-on
imimaginer qu'un parti, en 2022,
enen octobre, va faire
unune campagne électorale
ouoù il va promettre de faire
unun référendum s'il est élu?
PePeut-on imaginer ça?
- - Pour vous, c'est de la foli?
- - Bien, pas de la folie!
MaMais c'est un manque...
c'c'est un défaut que
ReRené Lévesque n'avait pas,
c'c'est un manque de réalisme.
- - Est-ce que M. Legault,
enen terminant, M. Bouchard,
a a trouvé finalement la formul,
dede faire une coalition
etet de tenter d'exploiter ou
dede faire naître un nationalise
unun peu plus revendicateur,
mmême si on ne voit pas beaucoup
d'd'effets, là, dans les relatis
féfédérales-provinciales.
MaMais on le voit, il y a
unun taux d'approbation qui est
prpresque dangereux.
- - Oui, vous parlez de
ququel parti, là? De qui?
- - M. Legault.
- - M. Legault, oui.
- - Est-ce qu'il n'a pas trouvé
lala formule gagnante de
nanationalisme sans rupture?
- - François Legault, c'est
unun réaliste. François Legault,
lele François Legault que
jeje connais et que j'ai vu dans
l'l'action et que je connais
papar des relations personnelle,
amamicales, c'est un réaliste.
QuQui fait une bonne lecture.
IlIl fait une lecture de
lala situation politique.
EnEn politique, il faut savoir
lilire. Où est-ce qu'on est?
ReRegardons la carte puis
ouoù est-ce que je suis?
BoBon bien lui, il sait où on e.
IlIl a une bonne lecture de
lala population, actuellement.
EtEt on peut pas lui reprocher.
OnOn peut pas lui reprocher que
bebeaucoup de gens partagent
soson opinion. C'est la réalité.
AlAlors, actuellement, on peut
pepenser que si la tendance se
mamaintient, comme vous le diriz
RaRadio-Canada, on peut penser
quque ça va être une élection
dede maréchal, comme on dit.
MaMais est-ce qu'on peut lui
rereprocher? Parce que c'est
cece que la population veut.
- - Mais est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
unun danger que les oppositions
auau Québec soient tellement
fafaibles...
- - Oui, c'est pas bon.
JeJe vais vous dire, comme
jeje ne suis pas en politique,
jeje peux dire presque tout
cece que je pense.
- - Oui, vous pouvez.
- - Je suis un peu malheureux
dede voir ce qui arrive au Parti
lilibéral. C'est pas bon, ça,
popour la démocratie québécoise.
C'C'est pas grave pour l'électin
ququi va venir. Mais ils vont p,
jeje pense pas, faire un grand
rérésultat, pour envoyer
unun euphémisme. C'est pas grav,
çaça. Mais dans l'avenir, il fat
quque ce parti-là se reconstitu.
OnOn dirait que les gens ont
ououblié... Je dis ça amicaleme.
- - Oui, oui, oui.
- - J'ai beaucoup d'amis dans
lele Parti libéral. Mais on dirt
ququ'ils ont oublié ce que c'est
quque leur parti. Leur parti,
c'c'est une coalition de
frfrancophones nationalistes,
mamais fédéralistes et avec les
ananglophones et les communauté.
C'C'est une coalition. Donc,
çaça prend un orfèvre pour virer
unune coalition. Il l'avait avec
RoRobert Bourassa. Il l'aurait u
avavec Mario Dumont. Mario,
c'c'est un orfèvre du même genr.
MaMais le Parti libéral va devor
sese reconstituer. Pas essayer :
bibien là, il faut plaire
auaux Anglais une journée,
lele lendemain, il faut plaire..
VoVoyons, ça marche pas, c'est s
çaça, la politique. Il faut avor
unun plan d'ensemble puis il fat
sese rappeler ce qu'a été le Pai
lilibéral, ce qu'il doit être
enencore. C'est un grand parti,
lele Parti libéral. Regardez
l'l'histoire du Québec depuis
5050 ans. Partout, vous avez des
ininterventions extraordinaires
dudu Parti libéral, un grand
papatrimoine, dont le parti peut
êêtre fier. Mais il ne faut pas
ququ'ils oublient ça. Il faut
ququ'ils reconstituent tout ça.
IlIl faut qu'ils se rappellent
cece qu'ils sont. Il faut
ququ'ils se rappellent que les
QuQuébécois, même fédéralistes,
leles francophones québécois, me
féfédéralistes, même fédéralist,
ilils sont nationalistes.
EtEt ils y a beaucoup de chefs
dudu Parti libéral qui
l'l'ont oublié, ça.
- - Vous dites : c'est un...
c'c'est un élément essentiel
dadans la dynamique politique.
MaMais c'est comme si, déjà,
vovous escomptiez la disparition
dudu PQ dans votre analyse.
CÇa n'existe plus.
- - Bien, je l'escompte pas,
jeje dis pas qu'il va disparaît,
mamais je vois... Il faut
ququ'il refasse son projet.
S'S'il veut durer, s'il veut ête
pepertinent, c'est un parti qui
dodoit refaire son projet.
IlIl faut qu'il ait le courage
dede le faire. Le Parti québécos
n'n'a jamais été capable de faie
dedes analyses en profondeur por
sese remettre en question.
QuQuand j'étais là c'était pare.
J'J'ai pas été capable non plus.
PuPuis M. Lévesque a vécu
lele même problème.
- - Donc, popour vous...
- - Et M. Parizeau aussi.
SaSauf que M. Parizeau,
ilil leur disait pas mal
cece qu'ils voulaient entendre.
MaMais on a vu où ça a mené.
- - Lucien Bouchard a été tentée
fafaire naître une troisième vo.
NaNationaliste, mais sans projet
dede référendum. Il a plutôt
chchoisi sa famille, ses deux
fifils. Et s'il ne sait pas
cocomment le projet souverainise
évévoluera, quelle forme tout ça
prprendra et même si ça arriver,
ilil sait par contre que pour
ququ'aboutissent des rêves,
ilil faut des leaders qui
ininspirent.
- - Si on veut réanimer la vie
popolitique, si on veut restaurr
leles bases d'une opinion publie
vivigilante, active, amener
leles jeunes à entrer en politie
acactive, parce que les jeunes,
ilils ne sont pas là,
vovous le savez, actuellement.
IlIl faut qu'ils reviennent.
IlIl faut qu'ils soient présent.
IlIl fait qu'ils reconstituent e
pepersonnel politique québécois.
IlIl faut qu'ils refassent
lele leadership. Bien, il faut
rerestaurer la mémoire de René
LéLévesque. Il faut rappeler
ququi était René Lévesque.
IlIl faut rappeler qu'il peut ns
ininspirer à beaucoup d'égards
etet que c'est quelqu'un qui est
dadans notre vie collective.
PuPuis heureusement, il est
dadans la tête de tout le monde.
SiSi on parle d'un premier
miministre, bien la référence,
c'c'est René Lévesque, hein.
C'C'est la référence.
AlAlors, on veut le rappeler
àà tout le monde.
- -